Watchmen is one of the most ambitious
and confusing new shows on TV like
there's these squids and elephant and
pigs and a catapult throwing clones on a
moon and there's Lube man amedeo mind
control magic eggs blue dongs flashbacks
and twists like the [ __ ] is going on but
there's also these serious heavy themes
of trauma and masks and race in America
and the whole thing's a sequel of sorts
to the original 1986 Watchmen a comic
book about superheroes the new Watchmen
is set 30 years later and its timeline
interconnects with the original to
reframe the story of heroes in America
so what happens in the new Watchmen how
does it connect with the comic and what
does it all mean
here's the basic timeline in the comic
the first masked hero was hooded justice
in 1938 he inspired the Minutemen a
group of heroes in the 40s in 1960 came
dr. Manhattan the only hero with actual
superpowers Manhattan won the Vietnam
War and Vietnam became a state of
America Richard Nixon stayed president
for decades in 77 heroes were banned
only Manhattan and the brutal comedian
could keep working for the government
in 1985 the main story begins everyone
fears nuclear war with Russia and the
comedian is murdered a weirdo called
Rorschach investigates along with Dan
aka
Nite Owl and Laurie aka Silk Spectre
Adri invade her rich narcissistic genius
attacks New York with a giant psychic
squid that looks like an alien as a hoax
to convince the world to make peace and
it works the cold war ends dr. Manhattan
kills Rorschach
to keep the hoax a secret dan and Laurie
fall in love
dr. Manhattan leaves earth and says
nothing ever ends so that's the original
comic the new show continues the story
in 2019 and adds world building about
the last 30 years partly on a website
called PTP dia so in the 90s Veit helped
real-world actor Robert Redford become
president Redford introduced liberal
policies like Redford Asians which gives
tax breaks to victims of racial violence
in response right-wing extremists
emerged like the seventh Cavalry a group
of white supremacists wearing
Rorschach's mask the cavalry works with
Cyclops an offshoot of the Ku Klux Klan
senator Kaine and police chief Crawford
are secretly Cyclops members and in 2016
they orchestrated an attack on police
called white knight a new law was passed
so police wear masks and Cain uses the
conflict between the cavalry and the
cops to gain political power in episode
1 2019
this guy will kills Judd and Angela
Laurie and Wade investigate meanwhile it
turns out that dr. Manhattan is in Tulsa
in human form as cow cane and Cyclops
capture him and try to take his power
but then trillionaire lady true kills
Cyclops to take Manhattan for herself
but then she's killed by squids so like
in the original comic the main heroes of
the story are barely involved in saving
the day the point of Watchmen is
exploring the lives and perspectives of
these characters so what are the stories
of eight will Angela Laurie Wade and
Manhattan Adrienne Veit was born super
smart and ambitious he idolized
Alexander the Great and the Egyptian
pharaohs so he took the name
Ozymandias and resolved to do great
things in the 50s he fought crime as a
hero but he realized that punching
criminals won't save the world they
decided to prevent nuclear war so he
quit being a superhero and built a
corporate empire becoming rich and
famous off electric cars like an 80s
Elon Musk in 85 he attacked New York
with a squid to end war he achieves
world peace but he kills three million
people leaving him feeling alienated
from humanity the TV show continues from
there so fate keeps raining squids down
from the sky keeping everyone scared to
maintain world peace fate influences
politics getting Redford elected in
92 and Veit asks redford to work with
him to build a utopia but Redford
doesn't listen Veit looses his influence
and popularity he becomes reclusive
frustrated and irrelevant in 2008 lady
true turns up and says that she is his
daughter because it turns out back in 85
one of eights staff called beyond stole
a semen sample from fate and impregnated
herself and gave birth to true true asks
for fates help and his money for her
plan to save the world by capturing dr.
Manhattan but fate is too proud and
stubborn and he rejects his daughter the
next year dr. Manhattan visits invade
gives him memory blocking device in
return Manhattan does a favor for Veit
Manhattan describes the world he's
created on Europa a paradise inhabited
by the kind and adoring Phillips and
Crookshanks Veit feels so hopeless and
defeated that he arks Manhattan to
teleport him there so fate lives on
Europa for eight years and it sucks
because the Phillips and Crookshanks
have no purpose no doubt no identity no
sex they're boring it's like living in
the Sims or in the Garden of Eden before
sin so fate makes a plan to escape
Europa back in o8 lady true mentioned a
probe she was sending to photograph
Europa which would arrive in 2013 so
Veit spends four years creating a
message for the probe to see he
catapults Phillips's and Cruikshank's
'as out of the bubble of life and onto
the surface of europa to die so that he
can use their corpses to spell out the
word save me daughter
so that true would say and save him the
way fate uses the corpses of his
servants is a lot like the black
freighter story from the original comic
in that story a sailor is stuck on an
island so he uses his friends corpses to
build a raft and sail home the comic
compares veyts feelings with the sailors
guilt and alienation over the years of
eight clashes with the game warden who
tries to stop fate escaping but in the
end fade reveals that he won
the warden to try to stop him fate
finally kills the warden with a
horseshoe that Philips tried to give him
years ago so it seems like this whole
conflict was scripted like the play that
Veit writes and like that absurd trial
where Crookshanks winks was fate really
struggling to escape or was this all
theater to keep himself busy till he
could leave fate needs drama and
adversity to thrive and he doesn't care
if innocents die for his pride true
seize the message and sends a spaceship
to rescue fate she freezes him in golden
Carbonite for the journey surveyed kind
of looks like yellow yolk within an
egg-shaped ship one of many references
to eggs this season fate arrives on
earth in about 2017 this meteor thing in
a flashback is Veit spaceship landing
but true doesn't unfreeze Veit right
away she is still angry that her dad
rejected her so she keeps bait as a
statue in a garden for years looking
like one of his action figures a
monument to his vanity true only thaws
wait out in the season finale because
she wants him to see her plan succeed to
prove she can win without him but just
as true was about to steal Manhattan's
godlike powers fate is teleported to his
base and he sends a frozen squid shower
to destroy true and half of Tulsa so
once again fate does something terrible
to supposedly save the world he kills
his own daughter who had just rescued
him from space to prevent her from
getting Manhattan's power but this time
he doesn't get away with it Wade and
Laurie arrest fate
so he'll finally be brought to justice
for his squid attacks which sucks for
him but on the upside he might finally
get that recognition and attention that
he so wanted aussi man Diaz's story is a
warning the too much vanity ambition and
pride can separate you from humanity as
though marooned on a distant moon wills
story stretches a hundred years from the
genesis of super here
to the present episode one starts in
Tulsa Oklahoma 1921 with the Tulsa Race
Riot this was a real historical event
where a mob of white people attacked a
wealthy black community killing many
people and destroying the neighborhood
young will loses his home and family but
he escapes like baby Superman had of
Krypton later will comes to New York and
becomes a cop
but the police are corrupt and racist
and Will's brutally attacked so will
becomes hooded justice the first hero in
Watchmen he saves a couple from being
mugged just like in the comic but will
uses white makeup to hide his race
fearing that white America wouldn't
accept a black vigilante so it turns out
the first superhero doesn't wear a
costume to look cool he wears a mask to
survive in an unjust society and the
noose on his neck is from his near
lynching he inspires the whole tradition
of Heroes in Watchmen but America thinks
he's a white man and never understands
the real story of hood at justice PTP do
compares this to the iconic western
movie hero The Lone Ranger who some
speculate may have been inspired by the
real world black lawman bass Reeves it's
an invitation to rethink the biases in
the stories America tells about power
violence and race as in the comic will
has a relationship with Nelson Gardiner
aka Captain metropolis and will joins
his group the Minutemen in the
background here you can see silhouette
Mothman the comedian and the first Nite
Owl wil uncovers a conspiracy by the KKK
groups Cyclops to use mind-control
against black people
we'll ask some entropolis for help but
he doesn't want to get involved the
Minutemen just want publicity some of
which perpetuates racism will is
fighting to protect a society that
doesn't protect him so will is angry and
frustrated and his wife and son leave
him Will's son eventually has a daughter
named Angela so will is Angela's
grandfather
fifty-five will breaks up with
metropolis quits the police and
disappears in 74 metropolis dies and
leaves all his money and his mansion to
will metropolis writes that he was wrong
to not help will and says that of all
the Minutemen only will was fighting
against true evil in 2009 dr. Manhattan
visits will because Manhattan fell in
love with wills granddaughter Angela and
Manhattan knows that [ __ ] will go down
so he suggests an alliance between will
and lady true to take down Cyclops
so in Episode one will kill Cyclops
member Judd Crawford using the same mind
control tech that Cyclops used back in
New York
lady true helps will by grabbing him in
a car so Angela can't arrest him and in
the finale true kills the leaders of
Cyclops after reading a letter written
by will about their crimes so 100 years
after the Tulsa massacre and New York
hooded justice finally gets justice
after a century of trauma will can start
to heal his wounds and to look to the
future he has a family now with Angela a
will story is about the long legacy of
injustice masks and pain in America and
looks to the potential for justice and
healing Angela was born in Vietnam in
the 70s
lots of african-americans moved there
after Vietnam became a state in 87
Angela's parents were killed in a
terrorist attack she identified the
culprit for the corpse and got her first
taste of justice from police work she
also idolized sister Knight a badass
movie superhero
so Angela grew up an orphan and became a
cop in Vietnam in 2009 she's alone and
empty and grieving then this blue
[ __ ] turns up and says he's in
love with her dr. Manhattan experiences
the future and past all at once so he's
in love with Angela before he even meets
her Manhattan says that their love will
end in tragedy but all love ends in
tragedy so [ __ ] it they start a
relationship to hide the fact that
Manhattan is a blue or powerful God he
takes the idea
and appearance of a dead guy called Cal
after the random tragic death of her
parents Angela finds it reassuring that
Manhattan knows the future but it can
also be really annoying to have a
boyfriend who knows everything and fears
nothing
Manhattan's previous girlfriends
complained of the same so Manhattan
decides to become more like a normal
human for Angela
he gets wait to give him a device that
blocks his memory
Manhattan stops using his powers because
he doesn't remember he has them he
temporarily sacrifices his godhood for
Angela they get married moved to Tulsa
Angela joins the police and they start a
life together but in 2016 the cavalry
attack on white knight
a gunman almost kills Angela but a
fail-safe in Manhattan's memory block
kicks in and he saves Angela by
teleporting her attacker away that's how
Joe keen finds other Manhattan is in
Tulsa and starts planning to capture him
dozens of police are killed on white
night including Angela's police partner
Doyle so Angela and Cal adopt Doyle's
children topher Rosie and Emma after
white night Angela pretends to quit the
police and start a bakery but secretly
she takes the identity of sister Knight
she hides her pain behind a mask and
fights for justice judd and jane
crawford make friends with Angela and
Cal but only because the Crawfords and
Kane are planning to betray and capture
Manhattan so the Crawfords are
incredibly cold and manipulative in 2019
angela meets will and experiences his
memories and learns that she's part of
his legacy
of survivors and fighters and masks
Angela learns of the plot to capture
Manhattan so she removes his memory
device and fights to protect him
Manhattan tells her that she can't save
him but she fights for him anyway
and Manhattan says that that's why he
loves her her determination and love in
the face of the pain and adversity that
she's faced in the end Angela loses
Manhattan just as she lost her parents
but before he died Manhattan said that
he could put his powers in an air
so that someone else could get his
powers Angela eats Manhattan's egg and
tests to see if she can walk on water
and then the season ends so does Angela
get Manhattan's godlike powers
should she the season explores how power
can be misused by Veit cane true and by
Manhattan himself but maybe after her
experiences angela has the right
perspective to do some good Angela a BA
was named after an old movie called a
bar the first black Superman maybe
Angela a bar is the hero the world needs
maybe Angela doesn't want to be a hero
anymore after what she's been through
the ending is ambiguous it's entirely in
your hands dr. Manhattan was once an
ordinary boy called John in the 30s he
and his father fled Germany for an
English manor John saw the Lord and lady
of the manor having sex and John stole
an apple
this represents the Bible story of the
forbidden fruit with Adam and Eve the
Lord and Lady give John a Bible and
described the story of Genesis with God
making the world they asked John to
create something beautiful so 50 years
later John as Manhattan creates life on
Europa in the image of the Lord and Lady
and their Manor because while Manhattan
is godlike he's not very original in the
original Watchmen John and his father
moved to New York where his father was a
watchmaker John became a scientist and
in 1959 he suffered an accident that
ripped his atoms apart but like a
watchmaker he reassembled himself and
returned as dr. Manhattan in the TV show
of eight writes a play called the
watchmakers son which retails this story
of Manhattan's Genesis man hadn't won
the Vietnam War for America which leads
to Vietnamese nationalists terrorism
including the attack that killed
Angela's parents so indirectly Manhattan
causes Angela to be orphaned Manhattan
has a relationship with Laurie aka Silk
Spectre aka agent Blake in 85 Manhattan
Fox off to Mars cuz his sick of humans
they're [ __ ] but Lori convinces
Manhattan that human life is special
because of its improbability the
thermodynamic miracle at the end of the
comic Manhattan leaves earth to create
life elsewhere so then in the show
Manhattan creates life on Europa he
creates Phillips and Crookshanks to be
better than the humans of Earth to be
kind and gentle beings in a new Garden
of Eden but paradise gets boring and
after 20 years Manhattan returns to
Earth to meet his love Angela Manhattan
visits will and starts the alliance with
lady true to stop Cyclops Manhattan does
this knowing that it'll lead to his
death but Manhattan has experienced the
future and he knows it's inevitable
Manhattan becomes cow blocks his memory
and spends ten years with Angela until
Angela makes him Manhattan again in the
finale true destroys Manhattan and as he
dies Manhattan experiences every moment
he was with Angela all at once and he
dies telling her he loves her so the
original comic explored how superhuman
powers can be dehumanizing God wouldn't
care about people but Watchmen 2019
takes a different perspective exploring
how Manhattan's powers make him more
human an infinite God of infinite love
he experiences past present and future
all at once so he is forever an innocent
child a dying scientist a god a husband
and lover all at once from his
perspective outside time not even death
can end his love because nothing ever
ends the Bible staff comes full circle
as well because Manhattan knowingly goes
to his death sacrificing himself like
Christ only for his power to be
resurrected in Angela walking on water
like Jesus
so Manhattan was kind of useless in the
original comic like will says he could
have done more perhaps this sacrifice is
the redemption of a God know of dif
nothing else
dude hangs dong Lorie is the daughter of
Sally Jupiter aka Silk Spectre Sally
raised LA
to be the second Silk Spectre a
glamorous sexy superhero just like her
mom Laurie hooked up with dr. Manhattan
and retired from being a hero but
Manhattan's a shitty boyfriend so Laurie
leaves him and hooks up with Dan aka
Nite Owl Laurie and Dan failed to stop
was he man Diaz's plan but they bond
over rediscovering being heroes together
on Mars
Laurie finds out that her father is the
comedian the nihilistic brute who once
tried to rape her mother so Laurie is
devastated and feels that her life is a
cruel meaningless joke at the end of the
comic Laurie goes off into the sunset
with Dan planning to be heroes but
Laurie's attitude has changed she wants
a different costume with a mask and a
gun just like the comedian's costume so
in the new Watchmen according to PT
pedia Laurie started calling herself the
comedian after her father Laurie and Dan
worked as heroes for a while but they
broke up because Dan wanted kids while
Laurie wanted guns and Dan felt that
Laurie was still in love with dr.
Manhattan so he made her a giant blue
dildo as a literal [ __ ] you the dildo by
the way is named Excalibur in the 90s
Laurie and Dan got arrested because
heroes are still illegal dan refused to
cooperate with the cops so he's still in
jail Laurie keeps an owl in a cage as an
ironic tribute to a night owl but Laurie
made a deal with the cops to let her go
free so long as she works for the FBI's
anti vigilante squad so Laurie goes from
a hero to a hero Hunter we see her
ruthlessly gun a man down and she takes
her father's name Blake Laurie has
embraced the comedian's dark legacy
because Laurie is hurt by a fucked-up
origins and by the feeling that dr. Mann
hadn't abandoned her she hides this
trauma behind a mask of cynicism like
the comedian she calls everything a joke
and laughs at the injustice and
absurdity of the world when she gets
captured by Cyclops she says she doesn't
care about their evil plan that she's
tired of all the silliness but in the
end
Laurie does
cuz cyclopses plan is to kill Lori's ex
dr. Manhattan and when Lori sees him she
shows some real emotion for once she
still loves Manhattan or at least is
nostalgic for a time when she felt loved
and later Lori sees Dan's old
airship Archie and she shows some
genuine or and joy again it's like
Lori's ex-boyfriends remind her of what
it's like to let down the mask and to
feel something real so in the end Laurie
and Wade arrest Veit for 30 years
Laurie kept the secret that Veit was
behind the squid attack but now she
changes her mind and decides to bring
some actual justice people change
she says I'm not joking she says because
now she's not being the cynical comedian
she's doing something she actually
believes in to make the world better
so it's subtle but Lori's story takes
her away from the cynicism of her father
and towards some sincerity and hope Wade
is a new character in Watchmen his story
begins in 1985 the night of a squid
attack Wade is a Jehovah's Witness
evangelizing at a carnival under the
shadow of imminent nuclear war he meets
some not tops who were like a punk
subculture from the comic and an autop
seduces him which is a challenged away
it's religious faith this temptation is
a formative moment for young Wade like
John taking the Apple like biblical
original sin Wade tries to grow beyond
innocence but the girl betrays him and
as if that wasn't enough humiliation
then the world [ __ ] ends the squid
hits New York sending a psychic
shockwave that kills 3 million people so
this religious kid tries one time to get
his Watchtower wet and the result is
unimaginable horror
Wade is scarred and grows up to be a
damaged lonely person his relationship
with an ex fails because he can't trust
anyone because when he was vulnerable
before he was shamed and traumatized
he's paranoid hyper vigilant for more
squid attacks so he lives in a bunk
and wears a tinfoil hat Wayde runs a
support group for survivors and he says
that he's no longer afraid but that's a
lie
Wade wears a mask to hide his pain after
white night Wade became the hero
lookingglass an expert at interrogation
and detecting deception which the exact
skills that could have helped him with
the girl in 85 in 2019 Wade goes out
with a woman from his support group but
she turns out to be a Klansman who
tricks Wade in to capture so once again
when Wade is emotionally vulnerable with
someone it just gets him another kick in
the balls Wade finds out that the 85
squid attack the catastrophe that broke
him was a hoax by Adrian Veidt so Wade
questions his whole life is anything
true he asks in the finale Wade goes
deep into enemy territory and faces the
man who caused his trauma and Wade
arrests him with a spanner Wade finally
gets justice and he takes off his mask
he takes the first steps towards healing
so in some ways Watchmen 2019 is cynical
it's about racism violence and trauma
the utopian dreams of Adrian Veit and
Lady Truth fail dr. Manhattan the god
figure dies but the story also has hope
will achieves justice and healing after
centuries of injustice and pain Angela
gets godlike power probably Manhattan
becomes a figure of transcendent love
Lori achieves some optimism and Wade
gets justice we also got an entire
season of Jeremy Irons eating cake and
playing with catapults so Watchmen 2019
isn't about superheroes conquering evil
but it is about some people who find
hope and healing
despite the darkness the main symbol of
the original Watchmen comic is a bloody
smiley it appears all throughout the
comic because it represents how the idea
of a hero is broken outdated and
degraded but Watchmen 2019 uses the
symbol of an
egg eggs appear all throughout the show
the season ends with an egg because an
egg is the opposite of the cynical
bloody smiley eggs represent rebirth
possibility and life thirty years after
the original comic this new show brings
hope to Watchmen thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video please like and
subscribe
they take a lot of work to make so you
welcome to support on patreon for
updates live streams votes and more
thanks to patrons Rodney get cell
hassancop Alani Mike curry James
Butterworth Veronica Van Cleve Seeley
and Sidney Cohen Cheers
you